well sherry drinks heat wave you may
want to head maybe to the pool
the lake to cool off we're gonna need to
live in the pool or the lake john for
the next couple weeks it's gonna be hard
to try and stay cool but you know with
these extreme temperatures there are
some things that you really need to do
in order to stay safe when you're
outside trying to also stay cool bianca
holmen live this morning at desert
breeze park to share some of those ideas
bianca good morning looks nice there
hey john hey alex i can't believe that
at five in the morning this 81 degree
pool water
is feeling very very nice right now and
a lot of you all probably making plans
to head out to the lake head out to the
pool because it's going to be another
hot one
today so we're joined here by travis
smith thank you for waking up early with
us
y'all are busy this week i can imagine
yeah no it has been
crazy there have been so many people
coming out to the pool they're ready for
summer they're ready to have a good time
yeah and i know of course the time that
they tell us not to be outdoors two to
seven
that's when people are coming ironically
enough yeah that is our prime time here
at the pools
but also what is in place i guess to
help protect folks i know of course
staying hydrated is very important
what are those brakes like yeah so one
of the biggest things we do is every two
to three hours at our pools
we actually force people to take a break
we call it a safety break so our
lifeguards get everyone out of the pool
and that gives us an opportunity to go
around and remind people drink some
water
put on sunscreen get in the shade yeah
so swimmers you can still
experience heat exhaustion correct yeah
one thing that people don't think about
is when they're in the water they don't
realize they're sweating because they're
already
wet but it still is hot outside and you
still are sweating in the pool
all right again some wonderful tips that
we need reminders of
and of course we've got some more things
that you want to keep in mind when
you're headed out to the pool and making
plans to cool off later on today going
to send it back to you guys in the
studio
all right bianca thank you so much that
pool is going to be packed here
later today